[Applauso]
[Musica]
l'ultima volta vi avevamo detto che era
l'ultimo video di scary tiziano infatti
il vero primo video perché sono vinti
tutti i livelli abbiamo finito il gioco
ma oggi sono usciti nuovi livelli di tre
nuovi livelli noi siamo troppo troppo
contenti di emozionati di vedere come
sono i nuovi scherzi alla maestra
cattiva scheri tease
grazie per aver sottoscritto in
tantissimi come livelli sono sicura che
saranno super divertenti anche perché ci
sarà nuovamente dracula e riti cervaro e
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri video con script hitler o
magari possiamo giocare all'altro gioco
ed iscritti già riso ma l'estate un bel
mi piace over rete perseguitati dalla
maestra cattiva mister a seguirmi no e
anita stories se volete seguito vi anche
se tik tok mettetevi comodi perché
questo video sarà super divertente
iniziamo con il primo scherzo che
sarebbe il terzo scherzo di halloween
british air è pronta tipo a lanciare
qualcosa di molto grande ma alla fine
sarà lei accade
come finito sto facendo ballare il
fidanzato mi sto parlando contro ma non
si sente in pratica allora cosa sta
succedendo sicuramente devono fare
un'altra dance competition e cioè
un'altra competizioni di ballo scheri
tiziano il fidanzato perché lei le stava
urlando contro di fare pratica e
diventare appunto un bravo ballerino
anche addosso dando un hamburger e lui
gli ha detto ma perché devo fare io
tutto il lavoro duro e lei gli ha detto
non mente o inventi una cosa e si è
visto un libro di incantesimi
quindi cosa vorrò fuori spiriti 0ra
usare un incantesimo sicuramente per
vincere la competizione in cui magari
francis metà bravissimo ballare bravo
ballerino oppure lei è troppo bella io
adoro i livelli di halloween perché
sapete che noi adoriamo le cose paura o
fermo e lo sapete dai video quindi tutte
queste decorazioni questo ambiente alza
al buio con i colori viola arancione
adoro prof
mi piace un sacco proprio come hanno
arredato tutta la casa hanno messo un
sacco di cose zucche candele ragnatele
anche le forze sono troppo belle
scriveteci nei commenti se voi preferite
la casa normale a muoversi e paurosa di
halloween cosa c'è scritto
dobbiamo trovare la chiave per
aprirli propri popoli e quindi cosa
dovremmo fare mentre colpite nel libro
magari il ragno come l'altra volta
oppure si guarda qua c'è un libro ma che
bella riaprire il troppo bello che mi
hanno fatto i livelli c'è qualcosa ciao
piccolo bravo lei trovato subito ha
detto se vuoi quello che c'è dentro al
libro devi essere pronto a pagarne il
prezzo può essere posta arrivano credito
è ok dove va a parare il mio mosca
appare ma mi ha avuto sei in tempo a
vedere tutto l'indovinello ma dovevo
scappare più che non sopporta di porta
abbiamo aperto dobbiamo avvenuto tutto
rifare tutto da capo
nel frattempo sto pensando alla
soluzione del caso pinelli allora in
pratica l'indovinello diceva adesso lo
rivediamo ma disse lo vediamo se
riuscite anche voi a indovinare prima è
che troviamo la soluzione sono qualcosa
che può essere tirato ma non sono una
gomma della macchina 8 e sogni fluido
del corpo quindi pensavo allora
rivediamolo ok dice che un fluido del
corpo che viene bevuto da un vampiro
quindi è sicuramente stata anche perché
ok maldini
ok basta indovinare anche voi
l'indovinello dice qualcosa che dà la
luce ma non è un grande dolore è
qualcosa che tu soffin nel giorno più
bello abbiamo lampadina una luce una
fotocamera è una canea cos'è una candela
da torta no forse è un compleanno
allora reach è qualcosa che vedo con il
mio occhio e uno sul posto che è stato
cotto in una torta e un po complesso la
zucca file la torta della zucca no
cuoci la zucca che diamo premio premio
abbiamo un incantesimo ok ma siano
broccolo nuovo incantesimo wow anche
bella dobbiamo scappare dagli amici di
ma le pratiche scritti cielo così il
nuovo inq antefisse scritto possiamo
normale allora il libro degli
incantesimi pensavo fosse quello mar
in effetti non è il suo libro di
incantesimi quello era un libro magico
che parlavano bravo ok
mettili in grande stima come lo mettiamo
l'incantesimo forse ci serve
qualcos'altro
ok chiudila secret i coscritti giorno
non capisca quello che hai fatto che
bastava campione chiuso ora di scappare
scappato resta qui
no non proprio adesso che abbiamo fatto
tutto ciò ci ha mostrato morto a sei
mancato poi di aver fatto tutto il
proprio valore alessandra adesso
[Musica]
wow no è caduto il fusione degli incanti
litigi ne fregano tutti bravissimi
se ne sono accorti abbiamo perso lo
scherzo perché il foglio è caduto si
scusano incollarlo
non ce l'abbiamo ben caldo ma ora
riproviamo comunque è stato bellissimo
vedere scritti ok ragazzi abbiamo
rifatto il tutto abbiamo l'incantesimo
in mano questa volta prendiamola come
nell'anno e incolliamo la pagina
dell'incantesimo al libro di incantesimi
sperando che schieriti certo però devo
dire che ne possano per fallire lo
scherzo perché sono troppo bello vedere
scritti per ballare anzi la riguarderà
10.000 volte troppo bella per la scena
ok chiamiamo incantesimo poi mettiamo la
terra a chi uni chiusi libro
ok ok che in realtà forse c'era questi
ribelli di halloween sono i miei
preferiti sono troppo bay infatti
benissimo un nastro per bellissimo
ambientazione colori bellissimi musica
bellissima scheri ti cerchi bar ma cosa
si vuole di pipistrelli qua forse c'è
dracula dracula nascosto da qualche
parte forse qui nel nel sarcofago
no non si può meglio negli armadi ma
questa è l'assenza di fantastica è
troppo bella
arriva il giorno quando non deve
prenderci ma con molta calma
[Musica]
poi vabbè cadere troppo bello e teacher
pensava di potere c'era la competizione
comunque aumentare e vincere la
competizione con il suo nuovo animale ma
l'unica l'unica che è urlerà aiuto e che
ricerco animale
una pianta carnivora anni
e letizia sta diventando si attiva
soprattutto in questi episodi di
halloween è praticamente cosa ha detto
che lei ha un nuovo animale animale tra
virgolette ed è una pianta carnivora al
gigante ha detto che vincerà la
competizione facendo spaventare i
giudici della competizione e come farà
praticamente deve mettere la foto dei
giudici dentro alla scatola così la
pianta carnivora li vede gli riconosce
se vuole anche che carrillo allora che
cosa dobbiamo fare dice fai in modo che
il a rimanere altri attacchi che eri
teacher quindi immagino che dovremmo
mettere una foto di scary tizio era
invece che dei giudici come facciamo
però per una foto scritti ser dovremmo
trovare qualcosa tipo una macchina
fotografica
io la macchina faceva al collo sono
fatti vedere
[Musica]
dobbiamo rubarglielo quale era uno
scherzo in cui iscritti sharif notiza va
prezzi cosa succedeva vediamo chi se lo
ricorda chi ha visto tutti i nostri
mezzi
giochiamo spiriti faccia ormeggio stato
il merito va piano piano di via virtù
meno macchina fotografica o no ma solo
c'è scritto di di fare una foto a
spiritismo usando questa camera ma se
noi facciamo una foto scritti fermo a
fare una foto 4 ago di noi dobbiamo per
forza affrontare scheri teaser e anche
perché sennò avremmo perso sicuramente
perché lei avrebbe preso se avesse visto
che le foto comune o fu vice di mettere
la foto anno dice di dare la foto a
francis per metterla poi nella scatola
della pianta ok la prima di scappare
prima che ieri di sé si trovi quindi
bastava metterla addosso france e
speriamo che funzioni ma per ati che
bello anche giardino che tutte le cose
paura le decorazioni mi hanno messo
dovere tabella la casa con i temi i
limiti devo pirati la luna dietro è
troppo bello scritti sono persone a lui
[Musica]
ecco i co
magic dai noi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
massimo scherzo ieri tizio avrà una
battaglia epica contro victor victor e
il bambino avanzato dracula victor
vampiro che andrà incontro a un epico di
stato credo succederà vediamo
[Musica]
allora l'obiettivo è di trovare la la
maestosa bacchetta magica
praticamente che cosa ha detto e adesso
che ha appunto questa bacchetta magica e
stava preparando una strana pozione è il
fidanzato fluence le ha detto
quel giorno stiamo bene attenti a fi
giocando col fuoco
quindi è una bacchetta magica molto
pericoloso secondo me si sono infilate
harry potter riguardo la bacchetta di
sambuco e anche come faceva di
incantesimi un po trasfigurazione un po
cruccio insomma ispirati assistendo è
comunque povero francis ne subisce
sempre di tutti i colori che ha
trasformato in rado di riposo per tutti
i colori vivi dobbiamo trovare la
bacchetta e penso che dobbiamo rischiare
qualcosa nella pozione perché li stava
preparando una pozione speriamo di
riuscirci stiamo un po cercando in giro
per la casa gli fa aprire la pasta miele
godrà ora sta dormendo per fortuna
altrimenti ci avrebbero preso con
l'apposita a ne abbiamo un rosato tipo
la collana una moneta d'oro
forse dobbiamo metterlo nella pozione
che rivincere dracula sembrano molto
molto vicini edipo si scambiano l'enel e
secondo me scritto qualcosa vuole
riportare trappola che cosa è un dente
di un gruppo di lupo malefico lupo
mannaro
sicuramente dobbiamo trovare la
bacchetta uoc bellagamba anche il bagno
pauroso sta salendo
[Musica]
dobbiamo trovare questa bacchetta di uno
scherzo ma non si stanca mai
arrivavano i falsi perché ok ok anche
provato a finalmente si è fermata non
riuscito a scappare giusto in tempo
bene allora direi di salire dalle scale
da fuori così arriviamo prima di sopra
cos'è questa una stella presa usa questa
chiave per sbloccare la calcio che ha la
bacchetta magica
quindi noi abbiamo questo meglio che non
abbiamo trovato ancora lo bacchetta
perché sarebbe stata in una scatola e
avremmo dovuto sbloccarla ma non avevamo
né la mia va adesso abbiamo la chiave
possiamo sbloccarla anche se ancora non
sappiamo dove la maglietta va la
troveremo mai quasi qualcosa lì sul
tavolo resta venuto un pacchetto marra
disse ho inserito in acqua
ok ti prendi la bacchetta dice trova un
modo per divertire la magia della
bacchetta forse dobbiamo andare fuori
dove c'era la pentola con la pozione e
mettere questo medaglione che abbiamo
trovato ma dov'è finito il dente di lupo
prima avevamo anche il tentativo non
andiamo più come ho fatto io sono più
portate rilanciato per sbaglio siamo
romperla con questa la bacchetta eccomi
neri potter
forse bisogna rompere la mia lotta
funzionato se sì credo però bacchetta di
sambuco anzi credo che cosa ha fatto che
però dobbiamo ancora trovare un modo per
invertire la mattina della baa che forse
proprio nel calderone si prova nel
calderone magari dobbiamo mettere questo
medaglione del vampiro proviamo con i
litri calderoni in quali dovremmo
mettere anche colore
abbiamo in quello verde a guarda c'è un
folletto tic e allora dice di dare il
gol per loro al gol in
noi dobbiamo dare a ogni poter poi gli
dobbiamo dare la bocca ha trascritto di
metterla dentro il calderone ok mettila
avere la bacchetta rotta affetto dove
l'occhio magico o no dopo che avessimo
finito li avessimo fatto tutto invece
dobbiamo trovare l'occhio ma forse a che
fare con il dente di luppolo l'occhio
magico e penso che dobbiamo mettere
degli ingredienti lì nella porzione dove
lo troviamo quarta quest'anno tomba a
prospetta lì c'era una pala
questa è l'unica bomba
stavo inquietante bravo prendiamo la
palla e speriamo che sia lì questo
occhio magico così riusciamo a
completare lo scherzetto per feriti lei
può vigilino vicino alla piscina con il
fatto scoprire aiuto ai pozzo non se n'è
accorta lo sai
il punto strano ma sbrighiamoci ok aiuto
ma qui abbiamo controlliamo meglio non
c'è neanche qui vivo ricorrere agli
aiuti li dividiamo l'indirizzo disegno
studiosi gli occhi magi sisti lumi di
base illumina dice che gli occhi sono
nella cantina quindi abbiamo vivo ad
altro bambino
questo scherzo davvero complicato
bisogna fare un sacco di cose non
sapevamo cosa fare quindi dobbiamo
andare proviene da fuori provincia
sappiamo che si è fatto allora nello
scantinato
abbiamo delle partite questo non si può
aprire così si può aprire questa ma c'è
qualcosa qui a sochaux che gli occhi che
brillano lo abbiamo trovato
ma forse era questo e cosa che mi è
caduto il dentro non ci credo non lo so
ma ho fatto per darlo lì che fortuna c'è
come il voto a ritrovare desisti scalo
per terra
bene adesso abbiamo se no chi corrente
speriamo che siano stati gli ingredienti
che non ne manchi qualcun altro ne
vediamo cosa succede
dai speriamo che ce la faccia questa
volta io ma dal goblin allora il massimo
anche questo calo radice di mettere
l'occhio nel calderone
ok che noi lo mettiamo poi dice di
mettere il dente ok trova un oggetto per
tagliare i capelli della rega cosa hanno
verissimo questa sera diretto ma quali
la strega o forse la strega che abbiamo
qui nel abbiamo trovato qui nella bara
a tagliarle i capelli con che cosa
dicesse ok abbiamo preso la forbice
ora non ci resta che stare attenti
scritti da quello del cappelli no no io
ricordo napoli teater già glieli abbiamo
utenti è stata fatta pelata americana
l'altro è uno scherzo
quindi tagliano i capelli alla strega
non sbarra e speriamo che sia l'ultimo
ingrediente che non dobbiamo trovare
altri tre e proprio lì ok forbici
speriamo che funzioni però preso lo
sciopero ha tagliato i capelli ma sarà
una pozione polisucco a galla tra frega
ok liste non andò ad esser dalla cucina
aspettiamo un secondo ok ok lontani da
tano però se mandare salutiamo sfida
contro il bambino dracula
la bacchetta dice di prendere la nuova
bacchetta noi abbiamo trasformato la
bacchetta e metterla nella scatola dove
l'abbiamo trovata camera di ieri tizio
quindi questo dovrebbe essere l'ultimo
passaggio cioè mettere la bacchetta che
noi abbiamo modificato nella stanza
iscritti cercasi lei non sa aspettare
niente o che scappa prima di scappare
speriamo di aver messo tutti gli
ingredienti di aver fatto tutto così
questo scherzo cambiavo scappiamo
capiamo chissà come si rimarrà a dracula
che abbiamo un manomesso la bacchetta la
strega si rubava
ok allora questo caso la super
divertente ma abbiamo deciso di vedere
cosa succede se falliamo lo chiudeva
così come il primo era super divertente
quando l'abbiamo fallito esperti perché
ballava la break dance
quindi abbiamo deciso di fallire questo
vedere che cosa abbiamo già preso la
bacchetta l'abbiamo rota abbiamo preso
il medaglione d'oro e volta proviamo a
non mettere gli altri ingredienti
siamo proprio successo quindi mettiamo
prima prima dobbiamo dare loro ora
koblin glielo diamo
ok la poi mettiamo una bacchetta e poi
invece di trovare l'occhio mettiamo in
evidente ma guarda escluso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non manca poi un bambino e una bambina
di un pipistrello malissimo
lo scherzo vince lei nello scontro punto
il vampiro che si vuole sempre vincere
le competizioni
oltretutto sono stati super divertenti
se gli scherzi con le tasse il suo
preferito quest'ultimo anche se stato
difficilissimo perché bisogna trovare un
sacco di cose è stato quello più bello
ma dobbiamo messo tutti gli ingredienti
oppure se la scoma che dipendenti è
stato il primo che si ha quando abbiamo
un fallito che ballavano breakdance ma
anche dopo come ballata del vostro
preferito
scrivetelo qua e cliccate uno di
pozzetta selina per rivedere tutti gli
episodi di spiriti stuber divertenti
oppure scegliete la casellina che prega
di debolezza